[Music]
these nuts were low against your chin
sexually of
[Music]
course hello
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
noise
[Applause]
noise
[Music]
[Music]
what you doing
i'm just noising your
[Music]
it's noise about the dancers
oh yeah
besides
i'm kind of the guy that says noise
noise what happened nothing happened i
just noised you because of you standing
up yourself and your place in this damn
circle no no no noise okay noise is my
thing
no more noise from you
excuse me
[Music]
oh noise
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Music]
noise
noise
noise
noise
noise
noise
[Music]
voice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
noise voice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Music]
noise
[Music]
[Music]
nice
vince
i uh i have that quarterly analysis that
you asked for
i had a quarter of these nuts on your
chin
right
it's just that i wanted to review some
of these numbers with you it seems like
our earnings are low against our
original projections
these nuts were low against your chin
[Music]
you know vince
if you ever need to talk to me about
something i'm more than happy to listen
these nuts will be more than happy to
rest against your chin
hey look you've been doing this for
about a week now and it was kind of
funny at first these nuts were kind of
funny against your chin
vince i'm worried about you
[Music]
i was worried about these nuts on your
chin this man seriously
[Music]
these nuts were seriously on your chin
mr graham i just got a call from st
mary's hospital and your parents were in
a serious car accident
i'm so sorry
but your mother is dead
and your father is on life support
these nuts are supporting life on your
chin
sorry amber
vince you gotta stop it
your mother just passed away these nuts
passed away on your [ __ ] no they didn't
they didn't vince
listen you got to leave here right now
and go be with your dad this could be
the last time that you get to see him
it's gonna be the last time i get to see
my nuts on your goddamn it vincent
your father might be dying
these nuts might be dying on your chin
god damn it fence snap out of it
your mother is dead
all right
you're right
you okay okay you're all right you're
back
i don't know what came over me that's
all right it was so good
it was just
it worked in every situation
i know i know and it's always it's just
so funny well it wasn't it wasn't that
funny it was funny
it really wasn't that funny vince
really funny
i would not go so far as to say it was
really funny vince was funny
but it wasn't though
it was
it wasn't
agreed to disagree it's funny okay
one more time i just got one record and
sing it wasn't really that funny
i got to see my dad
that was funny
wasn't that funny
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
that stay with me
dad
i love you
i love
these nuts on your chin
uh
[Applause]
you have a good time have fun have fun
dude i am sorry we're late man it
happens man she talked about how we're
supposed to be in the car at 6 45 i'm
like all right uh-oh
tell me my dumb ass ain't sitting in the
car waiting until 7 15. um okay when i
track my wife down 20 minutes later
she's stepping out the damn shower
talking about can i help you see that's
crazy right there craig i looked this
woman in the eye i said
[ __ ]
you told me 6 45. all right you said
that [ __ ] i said
[ __ ] then i laid it out but you said
[ __ ] though
you said [ __ ]
yeah
you gotta see the fireplace downstairs
in the living room
don't play games man just tell me what
you're doing exactly it's it's like say
what you mean mean what you say is that
so hard it's like last week man we going
out to dinner right i'm like where do
you want to go she's like you decide
uh-oh i'm like all right outback
steakhouse she's like nah mm-hmm like
straight up chili's she's like
no no daryl i named seven more wrestlers
no craig no finally said taylor's the
place i know she wants to go in the
first place right right she look at me
she said if that's where you want to go
no she did it right that's where i want
to go daryl i looked my woman in the eye
socket i told her straight out i just
said it man i said it i said i said i
said
baby i'm gonna take her back up to the
kitchen and show her the dishwasher
hey daryl yeah baby i want a kitchen
island just like the one upstairs yeah
you're gonna get it too
i love you
i love you
i said
if you wanted to go to taylor's just
tell a brother you want to go with
taylor
you said that oh hell yeah man i laid it
out right i said i said i said
i said
[ __ ] i'm the man of the house you said
[ __ ] though you called your wife a
[ __ ]
oh yeah
huh daryl where are those
guys i don't know let me show you this
so she's like why don't you win a movie
we both like no she didn't after i spent
25 minutes in the goddamn blog post
craig i looked this woman in her optic
stems and i said i said
i says
you said that ain't nothing but a thing
but you said [ __ ] though
yep
oh
hey honey uh craig just give me the
neighborhood tour
so then she's like i didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking nuh-uh i'm like i
didn't tell you to wear those shoes she
said don't raise your voice at me what
dare
roll
i look this woman
dead in the windows of her soul
i said
[Music]
i said
i said be
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh yeah good victory guys good victory
hey hey come on good game flap ass man
hey good game
yeah guys
man good games
[Applause]
hey who's next too hey garcia come on
man get you some come on let's get some
slap ass over here no
what why why not
i said no
rafi he's had enough rafi
we've all had enough
enough for why enough of the damn ass
slapping graffiti
gracias
okay
see yes
guys who cares how much i slap ass so
why that's not bad what's the deal man
i'm a [ __ ] baseball player
that's what we do we can hit home runs
and slap ass come on
huh rafi that's not how we all see
baseball everybody does it all the teams
slap ass man and yo yeah you slap ass
garcia like a couple of times a game
once oh what man why the county man who
knows how many times i slapped baths or
427
times
okay time flies when you're having fun
man what my family's going to these
games rafi
my son is always asking me why i'm
letting this man touch my butt so many
times and you say slap ass every time
every time okay hold on one second let's
go to the timeout
i'm from the dominican republic okay all
i know
since i was a little kid
is to catch fly balls and to say slap
ass every single time
it's not bad this is the major league's
wrapping we're all from the dominican
republic
nobody here
has ever heard anyone say slap us
before you
quit playing man come on get yourself
ass
rafi enough okay
[Music]
okay
you're right
i know you write about it
i have a problem okay
i know that
and i decided to stop right now when
right after i get that garcia flat pass
come on guys
hey come on huh i'm fine all right fine
i get it
hey garfield man can i talk to you for a
second oh hold up
hey rafi what's up
oh man
i just talked to the manager man
he says he's going to trade me man i
mean what the hell you know i got kids
too right yeah well we all told you what
was going to happen if you hey
i really could use that in one slap ass
man raffy come on man
just one slap ass you know
just one
just for old time's sake you know
get me back on my feet
just one for the road man i could really
use it
okay
okay
good game
i gotta get home to my case
ah
garcia man
i'll suck your if you let me slap your
ass again
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
man i felt sorry for that dude but you
know what you gonna do i had to lay that
down
what let me lay you down hey brother i
don't know where fight you was at they
got a couple of licks in sure but
i was like
man i put the [ __ ] on the chain wax
[ __ ] on the chain wax
is that a thing
well yeah that yeah that's a that's a
thing yeah yeah that's something
okay yeah i put the [ __ ] on the chair
[Applause]
i just um google [ __ ] on the chain wax
no results man um
why are you googling no i'm just saying
[ __ ] on the chain wax
it's not an expression
yeah it is yes thank you it's something
leo yeah what what what does it mean
then what does it mean
i'll tell you what it means it means
that
is that you put the [ __ ]
okay have either the two of you have you
ever
said the words [ __ ] on the chain wax in
any context
us
he talking you man he ain't talking to
me dude
hey man it's not our fault that you
ain't never put that [ __ ]
no one can put the [ __ ] on the chain
wax cause [ __ ] on the chain wax ain't a
thing
you trying to start a thing aren't you
what
i mean
what are you talking about trying to
start a thing a thing like off the hook
or i'm gonna put you on blast you trying
to get it in the effort so everybody out
there saying [ __ ] on the chain wax man
why are you doing this why are you
looking at what i'm saying and fact
checking my ass
you keep saying some
that doesn't exist
and you got thing one and thing two
corroborating your story like it does
and you why are you lying there it's
[ __ ]
body
[Music]
why do you care so much
[Music]
whether i made up
[ __ ] on the chain wax
or not
i lost my job
[Music]
my girl left me
and all all i wanted to do
was have a little bit of fun
[Music]
with my friends today
so why why do you ha why do you have to
belittle me like that
[Music]
it's just that i yeah
i'm just trying to say what you're
trying to say
i'm trying to say
that i want to put the [ __ ]
hey have you ever found yourself in high
porn north carolina and not feeling safe
come on down to doug duggar's brazilian
jiu jitsu
you will learn to tackle on grappler
like an ultimate fighting pro
in my studio you get hands-on training
and individual attention so
[Music]
tackle and grapple
take on multiple enemies
this is a tackle that's a grapple right
there
this is a tackle
that's a grapple get there we are
yeah
faculty
all ages learn to protect yourself and
your loved ones
[Music]
tackling rapping
there are many different levels there's
the beginning level and if you pass my
private one-on-one sensei trial
you may make it into the advanced class
tacoma rapper the duggars jiu jitsu at
the high point mini mall just east of
the pizza barn two doors down from
kyle's discount reels and furniture sit
quick tackle get down
uh triple mups
no steak stay away
special discounts for college students
i wake up next to this guy and
as usual i don't even know his name
i'm trying to get dressed quickly and
get out of there before he wakes up but
i can't find my underwear
i look everywhere but
i just can't find them
and then it hits me
i had left them at another guy's
apartment earlier that night
and that's when i knew i had a problem
[Applause]
thanks for sharing skype
well i noticed a lot of new faces this
evening
and i'm so glad you all came
and i want you to know
that this is a safe place to share
so if you want to tell us your story
there'll be no judgment
sure i'll go
hi y'all
name's wendell
and i am in fact
a sexual addict
i will know
and what brings you here wendell
well
you know my life
sexually
speaking it's crazy and i just want to
find
one
single solitary person
to spend the rest of my life with just
one
just one
so do you feel like your addiction is
too much to handle right now duh
i mean it's been crazy y'all
with me the nastier the better
i'm a dirty dog
try everything
all the fixings
tantric
much like sting
all the bells and whistles you name it
i've dunced it
and when would you say you hit rock
bottom wendell when it got slippery
outside my shower on the floor outside
my shower
oh
i hit rock bottom sexually
well probably last night last night do
you think that you could tell us what
happened wendell
yeah let's see uh it's just like any
other night i had ordered a large pie
pepperoni pineapple cheesy crust cheesy
bread on the side
i cut two
30 min later
pizza parlor sent over a delicious
lady delivery
person bodytan
face tan
that's my weakness
so i invited her inside
opened up the box it was hot
devoured the first slice lickety-split
crust first
second slice didn't stand a chance
ate the tip of that [ __ ] first washed
it down with a pop
then i got nasty with the cheesy bread
my heart started pounding harder than
usual cursed lunk
cursed slunk
moved on to the third slice
what about the girl what girl
oh the girl yeah she was there too
invited her into my boudoir aka the
stabbin cabin
we disrobed one another i touched her on
her genitalia she
touched me on my manitalia and that's
when i hit it
sexually
of course
upstairs downstairs all around the town
stairs as you do
and uh
by then it
was just another night and i mean
oil everywhere and
sauce
all over me
sauce
oh yeah that's my word for
ejaculate
anywho i'm so uh distraught because i
feel vulnerable and i don't know i just
feel like anyone
could take advantage of me right now and
knee
won
okay let's see what the blondes have to
say first
well thank you wendell um thank you for
sharing it's actually our time today
[Applause]
[Music]
yo hey y'all
hon y'all
excuse excuse me
oh man oh man oh man
i tell you one thing if 9 11's toward to
happen up on this here plane
don't worry we got this
okay
okay i have no idea what you're talking
about
he's saying
that fdm terry's just gonna try some up
in here today like the bounce boogie and
bump
that we got dick
do you mean terrorists
baby he ain't talking about terry guard
and i certainly ain't talking about no
terry cloth
i mean if a terry up on this plane he
was thinking about trying to do
something we're gonna wax him up
you you're gonna you're gonna what we're
gonna drax
you know
scouts
i think what my partner's trying to say
is if any terrorists come up in here we
gonna get our bergeron
did something happen or did i
miss something as hypothetical or oh
we're gonna definitely drop some
hypotheticals on that terry's clavicle
cause i'm talking about
don't you just wish so
don't you just wish in your heart of
heart
some terry would come up in here trying
some grab baths and the touchy feely
that's
the opposite of what i want to have
happen on a plane
okay
that's unfortunate
conference
this was unexpected it certainly was
i'm thrown right now as to who's going
to be our comrades he can still hear you
doesn't have the heart nor the gumption
you're literally right next to me oh
three
break
three
you who
i got an idea feel free to say no but
can we switch seats i will not take no
for an answer
why
that's the combat seat jonathan
livingston seagull
if you're going to be in the combat seat
then you guys to be willing to blast up
on some carries
because the great power
comes great
and relations
okay i just i just wanted some leg room
um
okay max leg room
you get yours meanwhile i'm gonna go
hayden pantaneeri on some terries
especially when they get froggy
rabbit baby
um you gonna have to be ready to kidnap
a terry i don't you're gonna have to be
ready to touch you a terry i don't think
that's necessary absolutely you have to
fire aboard those mother james
i don't even understand what that means
do you trust me no
i'll take that at the yeah okay
draft these terry's come up in here
trying to act froggy
then we gonna give them the rainbow
connection yeah
so won't get from getting from their
phone
box cutter oh you best believe it baby
we gonna be eating like diane keaton
2.35 inches baby [ __ ] wax
perfectly league well
and if those don't work
you know i'm working up that plan b
brother
oh yeah 3d printer baby 100
polyurethane they can't detect these
mammograms
oh
drax
hello
scouts
all right listen up y'all
i'm your substitute teacher mr garvey
i taught school for 20 years in the
inner city
so don't even think about messing with
me
y'all feel me
um okay let's take a roll here
jay quellon
where's jay quillinette
no jay quellon here
yeah
uh do you mean jacqueline
okay
so that's how it's gonna be
y'all to play
okay then
i've got my eye on you jay cuellar
but lake
where is balake at
just no no blocking here today
yes sir
my name is blake
are you out of your goddamn mind
blake
what
do you want to go to warble lucky no
cause we could go to war no i'm for real
i'm for real
so you better check yourself
d nice
is there a d nice
if one of y'all
says some silly ass name
this whole class is gonna feel my wrath
now d nice
do you mean denise son of a [ __ ]
you say your name right right now denise
say it right denise correctly denise
right denise right
nice that's better thank you
now
a-a-ron
where are you
where is a-a-ron right now
no a-a-ron huh
well you better be sick
dead or mute
a-a-ron here oh man
why didn't you answer me the first time
i said it huh huh i'm just you know i'm
just asking you i said it like four
times so why didn't you say it the first
time i said a-a-ron
because it's pronounced aaron
you dumb messed up hey ron now take your
ass on down to osak hennessy's office
right now and tell him exactly what you
did
who oh shag hennessy
principal o'shaughnessy get out of my
goddamn classroom before i break my foot
off in your ass insubordinate
and churlish
timothy
present
thank you
[Music]